now we're about to establish an
important piece of geography and break
it completely we've seen that hallway
before but this time the door Whateley
seems to lead into the kitchen you see
Kevin's modulated sense of concern now
growing into okay I think I need to run
hi i'm kevin bacon and i'm david kept
the director of you should have left and
we're here to break down a scene for you
[Music]
are you at the corner yeah you sure you
could let go
listening we we picked is about halfway
through the movie movie takes place in a
rural house in rural Wales very isolated
and Kevin's character and his wife
played by Amanda Seyfried in their six
year old daughter have come to this
house and started to notice things are a
little bit strange about the place and
unfortunately that's coincided with a
big some marital dust-up and Amanda's
character has left in Kevin's here alone
with the kid exploring the place they've
discovered strange things about you know
one of the great things that David did
when he wrote the script was he had
envisioned not a typical scary house
especially in the countryside you you
know you really think of like gothic
kind of places ivy-covered and creaky
old antiques and you know he kind of had
had a vision for something modern and we
saw the pictures of this house and it
was it was scary in and of itself
because I think both of this felt like
well this is the place and we don't
really have a plan B so before if you
really fall in love with a location like
that with with no other options that
could be a little terrifying when you're
making a movie but luckily we were able
to to shoot there
says this room is 5 feet longer on the
inside than it is on the outside wait
how does that work so you can see
they're in some really striking a
countryside and like like a lot of scary
movies we picked a place that was very
isolated in that isolation you know a
lot of fear can develop and so what
we're working with here is how to play
that tension from rising up from not
tense at all to a little bit worried to
really quite concerned if you're gonna
do a scary movie then probably your
character is going to be scared for
about at least 3/4 of the movie novalee
yeah and various various versions of
that playing that particular emotion
become challenging to try to you know
just come up with new ways to approach
it and it's the face and it's the body
and and everything but I find that one
of the fun things about a scene like
this is its it moves from being just
kind of odd to like weird to really
weird like you said and so that you so
that it's kind of built in the varying
degrees that I have to you know pull out
and portray
[Music]
ha what we're doing is really trying to
ratchet things up slowly so when a
little girl we get the sense that maybe
something is up by her delayed entrance
into the kitchen and because Kevin
starts to become concerned we start to
become concerned but not too much
because then she shows up and there's
the friendly little wave and then we
start the dolly across those outdoor
windows and it's really the simplest
effect in the world in terms of
camerawork what we were looking for on
this movie was to do things practically
as often as possible so the little girl
runs across or momentum very naturally
should carry us out of those doors but
we sneak a little cut as we passed the
brick there so we matched the speed with
the dolly and just jump cut in the brick
so you've never noticed and the camera
ends up where her body should have ended
up out in the hallway but she does not
Ella
hello something on the move for
hide-and-seek
hello I gave up money you and ella ella
okay al it's not funny come out please
[Music]
one of the great accomplishments of our
production design crew was that we shot
a lot of the stuff and obviously all the
exteriors of the house in Wales but then
moved back to London for a few weeks
where the where the set had been like
perfectly recreated except for the fact
that now things could move and expand
and there were some some slight kind of
design things that were recreated so
when you look at a sequence like that
correct me if I'm wrong dad but it's
we're cutting back from London to Wales
a couple of times yeah yeah the insides
of the house well there are a couple
different parts of the inside of the
house well some of it in Wales some of
it in London let's watch the rest of the
clip and see things start to really
freak out Ella now we're about to
establish an important piece of
geography break it completely we've seen
that hallway before but this time the
doorway leads seems to lead into the
kitchen
see Kevin's modulated sense of concern
now growing into okay I think I need to
run
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
was she undergone into there where it
takes him now is to a place that is
completely freaked out because now he's
seen a hallway that last time he turned
around was 10 feet long is probably now
75 feet long
we had endless conversations about
tracking exactly where I was emotionally
in the course not only of one sequence
like this which as we mentioned before
jumped from Wales to London and back to
Wales and and and back and forth but
also in the in the in a sequence of a
movie the genius of a premise like a
missing kid and it's not my premise so I
can say it's genius is you cannot leave
the house your kid is in that house
somewhere so even if this house is
behaving like a house from hell and not
following the rules of the universe you
can't there's nothing you can do you
should have left but it's too late you
can't now your kid is missing the sort
of granddaddy to into my mind of weird
house and you know family stories is a
Richard Matheson episode of Twilight
Zone called little girl lost which is
about a little girl who disappears in a
house one night sort of famously it was
a it was a big inspiration for
Spielberg's poltergeist and Matheson who
wrote the novel a stir of echoes that
movie Kevin and I did 20 years ago was
based on Madison was a genius at that
sort of inventive domestic horror if you
listen to our soundtrack as we're
dollying past the living room just
before the little girl disappears the
composer Jefferson le put in a little
twinkling and bells that evokes the
twilight zone theme which was sort of
our way of saying hats off to Matheson